Awesome. All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone. Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some rules and logistics. First of all, please mute yourself during the talk unless you have questions. You have questions. If you have questions you are welcome to mute and ask otherwise, please use the chat room to post your questions so that we can address them in q&a session at the end. Second, today's GDPR seminar is open to external audiences therefore no classified discussion is allowed. So please watch out. Finally, the talk today will be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about it. Now let me introduce our speaker today. It is an honor to host dispenser brings bring Gilson who is an assistant professor in the College of Computing at Georgia Tech. Previously, he was a senior postdoctoral researcher at Caltech with Tim colonias a visiting researcher at MIT with chemists SubSys and a postdoctoral researcher at the Center for exascale simulation of plasma coupled combustion with Carlos Pantanal and then Bodoni he received his PhD and MSc in theoretical and applied mechanics from the University of Illinois at Urbana Champaign in 2017 and 2000 kin working with the Jonathan fluid. In 2013. He received a bachelor's in science degree in both mechanical engineering and mathematics from the University of Michigan's Dearborn. Spencer won a few awards like the Young Investigator Award from Oak Ridge National Lab, the UI UC Outstanding Dissertation Award and the UC has an RF our full research in fluid dynamics. Today Spencer will talk about comparative physics informed networks, which is a very interesting topic. Please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk now without further ado, let me pass the baton to Spencer, by asking one random person really, really random questions. That random question is what is the most e rational superstitions you have? If you have one? Most irrational superstition that I have. I'm not a very superstitious person. Yes. But I guess maybe most scientists aren't. I don't know how to answer that question. Let me ask another question. Okay. You got it. Superstitious that consciousness is not real? How about that? Oh, okay. So weird. It's, it's a weird it's a weird, weird answer. But I think it's a it may be a somewhat controversial one. So I think I make sense. It's a perfect answer for the viewer the question, okay. Stacy's yours. Thank you young soon. Okay. Well, thanks, everyone, for having me. And thanks for the nice introduction. So physics and formed neural networks are a hot topic as Jung Soo has alluded to. And so we're gonna get down to some nitty gritty details here about what I think is going on in this research area. And maybe some of the problems that exist and some potential solutions to them, which I understand is a bit vague, but we'll get there. First, will do the acknowledgments at the beginning. So I don't forget. So really, the brains behind this operation are two outstanding students, seizing and Yash cathartic. They are two great students that work in my research group. I also have an outstanding collaborator, Professor Florian Schafer, who is also in the same department as I am and sitting a couple of offices away from me right now. So I'm very grateful for them. And they contributed to this work as well. And there's a paper that is associated with much of this work that you can refer to as as you see fit. It's on the archive, and it was just accepted to iClear 2023. Okay, so let's first do just a quick overview of what type of physics and form neural network is, even though maybe many people know but we'll do a quick introduction. So the idea of a physics form neural network is simply that, number one, your task is that you want to solve a PDE and The way you're going to do it is you're going to encode the solution to that PDE into a neural network, the neural network doesn't necessarily have a very complicated topology, it's in many cases, just a multi layer perceptron, though some people have experimented with different types of architectures. But at the end of the day, it's just a neural network in which you are encoding the solution to a PDE via training. And that's it. And then so in the way that this is done, is that the loss function for the training of this PDE is simply the mean squared error. So the difference between the exact solution to the PDE and, and the one that you observed, so this is but and so the magic of this, or the seeming magic of this, is that through backpropagation, you can get the all of these, you can accumulate the derivatives to any partial differential equation, you may have an ad, or ordinary differential equation, such that you don't actually need to really have any data on hand, all you really need to have is the PDE. And then I can then formulate what solutions or I can create a neural net, I train a neural network to represent its solution, which is a really clever little trick that sort of bypasses problems of oh, well, how do I come up with so called deal truth data, and so on, and so forth. And because of its simplicity, this is why it's so popular seemingly these days. But now, I thought, I'd be remiss without doing a little bit of archaeology here. So the idea of introducing physic physical constraints, in this case, a partial differential equation. But of course, one can imagine other physical constraints, being integrated into a artificial neural network is actually a rather old idea, or at least rather ruled by, by neural networks, standards, artificial neural network standards, and the research in the field. So if we actually go back to 1994, Thompson and Kramer, they introduced these ideas of intermediate variables and residual modeling, as a way of actually solving for for models. And now, they weren't necessarily solving PDS that may have been beyond their computational capabilities at the time, but they had this very similar fundamental idea. And so and so that was quite interesting. And it didn't really gain a tremendous traction at the time, but they had seemingly the core idea there that that comment seems to come ever so naturally to us, once, once, you're told that at the very least, there's also this idea of physics based pre processing, where you inject some prior physical knowledge, and then and then you train your neural network model. So you do this sort of ahead of time instead of during training. And so that that also has been around for a long time, at least since 1998, if not earlier. And so humans have, we have this idea that if our neural network isn't really doing what we want to maybe what we can do is we can just inject some physics in some sense, or some sort of mathematical representation of that physics. And that will make things better. And so it turns out that that idea is not extremely new. And we can go on and on in 2005, folks, came up with the idea of a finite element neural network where all of the weights that compose the neural network, were actually pre computed because people had an idea of what they should be to begin with, because people under have understood finite element methods for a long time. So people tried that as well and had some success. And then we go further and further. And there was some work in 2007, where people were incorporating physical models as neural network constraints and had more and more successes as more computational resources were available. So here, we're looking at something like a constitutive law on the top in order to get some temperature of a material. So none of these specific applications or ideas notwithstanding, the reason that perhaps they didn't get a ton of traction, is because maybe we just weren't quite ready for them. And or we didn't, both in terms of sort of computational horsepower, or in terms of the software tooling needed in order to make them easy to create. But it just so happens around, maybe the mid 2010s that these types of tools became common, some thinking of things like pytorch and TensorFlow and so on, as well as GPUs started exploding onto the scene where now sort of everyone can have access to GPU or a small cluster of GPUs, in order to train these things in between the two, it sort of was just the right sort of mixture of things in order to pop out these things deemed physics and formed neural networks, which is a quite similar idea, but it was just really came in at the right time. And, and, and showed all sorts of great examples about what these things can do. And so this is, of course, the the quite now famous paper of veracity prior to cartus, and George Krennic, daucus, that I think many of us are familiar with. So pins pop into the scene until the 19, though the archived version of their paper was, I believe, 2017. And so since then, we've had a bit of a research explosion in this area, basically, all of these papers in this review, so you can find this on the archive, and this is a separate paper are, are purporting to, to try to sort of hammer away at as they're attempting to hammer away at this problem. And in all sorts of from basically every different angle. And I think we're going to get to, in this talk, we're gonna get to the point of why so many of these papers exist, why we're looking at those references here, at least on this slide into the three hundreds. So part of this is because this tool is powerful, but part of it is because it actually needs some help. So I'm going to get to that next. Okay, so, so this is to bring us back after this short history lesson. This is again, what a physics informed neural network looks like. And, and I'll recall to you that this MSC here stands for mean squared error. So this is like an L two error on basically the difference between the solution or the residual of a PDE. So maybe you want to focus on this part where my pointer is this f minus Laplace you. So here, we're just solving up for song like equation. So this is the PDE residual, and then this other term is just sitting in for the boundary conditions, perhaps, is not especially important. But here this thing in the loss function, which is really the main meat of what makes up a neural network, and certainly how it is trained, is, is what's going on here. And so I, I suggest, and I hope to show some evidence that this is actually part of the crux of what will become a problem. Okay, so the problem here is that be these physics and form neural networks, if I give them a PDE, if I give them an IV, a stokes equations, if they give, if I give it even, seemingly sometimes quite benign, PDE s, or even odd is that it will struggle to come up with a accurate representation for the solution, it will the lot. And what I mean by that is essentially that the loss function will actually not decrease. Too, a very low level. So here, we're thinking about something on the order of like 1% l to error. And of course, it can be much worse than this. There are some cases where some PDS just do not train at all. So you start off with some error, and then nothing basically, nothing happens as you go through training. And this is well documented, I put some example papers here, there's probably been even more since since I first created the slide like a couple of months ago. So. So this is well documented. And the question is, well, what's going on here? Why can't I train my neural network my pin to represent this PDE wouldn't be so great if I could, and it turns out that it's not really clear what the reason is, because it's sometimes sort of puts its head in into it butts its head into seemingly benign PDS whereas for more complicated looking PDE, everything is just fine. And you get all sorts in the training error is quite low and everyone's happy. So the question is what what is going on here? So how do we fix this thing? And I hope to talk about that next. Okay. So, my suspicion here, which I hope to convince you of is that the main cause of this problem is that these problems are poorly conditioned. So the pin loss function is this L to like error or this squared error involving differential operators. Of course, they can be of higher differential order, which would only make the problem worse. And so but then, at the end of the day, Eight the problem we're actually trying to solve. So if we just think about this in the context of a discretize, linear problem and discretize, linear differential operator, so something, again, seemingly benign, in this case, upasana equation, then, then this is the problem that you're trying to solve here, right. And so we know that this is the solution to this minimization problem. And if you put this thing through gradient descent, this is going to be essentially what gets computed and the problem that that tries to get solved. Now, and you're solving here for you, that's the solution field that you want. And you can have the once you actually have that thing, you can evaluate it anywhere and say space, or if this was the pine time independent, you could evaluate it in time, and so on, and so forth. But, but if we remember our numerical linear algebra, we see that there's something quite nasty about this, this this problem, which is that this A transpose A inverse is actually a quite nasty thing. This is akin to solving the normal equations for a linear system, which squares the condition number of that operator. So if A is encoding any differential information, this is we're now squaring that condition number, which is something that we all learned that we don't want to do, sometimes when in during our schooling, and so this is essentially what's happening every step through evaluating the last and doing your gradient descent or however you would like to optimize your, your neural network, your your pin. Okay, so this seems to be a key a problem to what's going on. And so, instead, a way to fix this, partially is to get rid of this L two type business. But the problem is that you don't really want to give up this L two type property, because it has this nice convexity properties. And an L two is nice for all sorts of other reasons. So you don't really want to leave the L two space. And instead, you'd like to solve this and perhaps a different way. And so this is where we're, I think a reformulation of it, otherwise, the same problem is beneficial. And so here we are recasting the same problem, as instead a mini max minimization problem. So the minimax problem solution to the same problem. So here, we are minimizing now the solution to this PDE, where here pi steps in as the solution. So this is still the PDE residual in the parentheses. And then D serves as something that looks like a discriminator that is imposing penalties onto this thing. And so this is a so called mini max problem where the D is trying to penalize solutions that are poor. So it's trying to just try to penalize mistakes that are made by the approximation pi. And vice versa. Pi is trying to minimize the terms that are in parentheses, such that this is such that this is small. And so this is a back and forth game that is going on between these two agents. And so if you recast this minimax game into its linear formulation, which is is what's shown here, then it turns out that the condition number of this linear system has the same condition number as the original derivative operator. And so things are are better posed. And so that can save quite a bit of heartache. And I'll I hope to show you some examples about why why that that that are compelling that suggests that this is important. Okay, so the next question is that, that we need to implement this thing. So we have here, this minimax game and the top left, here's our PDE residual for our sort of toy PDE. The are our Poisson problem. And we have our discriminator hanging out here. And this is what the architecture looks like. So now we have two multi layer perceptrons. In this case, one serves as a neural network representing the discriminator. And the other serves as what we what is our good friend, the pin that is going to give us the solution, in this case pie. But otherwise, they're up to the same business except that they are now competing. But now we see that the loss function looks a little bit different. We have products here, for example, between D, the discriminator, and the the residual between the the residual of the PDE that we hope to solve. So we see that this no longer looks like an L two type mean squared loss function. This looks different. So that's what the architecture looks like. And now the next question is How does one actually go about optimizing such a type of game between this discriminator and this pin network. And so that's where this idea of competitive optimization comes in. So it turns out that this is a quite necessary task. And I'll make the argument for that in a moment. But what one can imagine in the sea pin instance, that's what we call it, these competitive pins is that the discriminator is acting as one agent that is trying to do what's in its best interest, which is to penalize the mistakes of mismatching the solution to the PDE. And the y is the actual PD residual, which is trying to be as small as possible. So these, this x and y, these two agents, x and y are in competition with each other. Okay, and so one can think about this as sort of like a cat, and a mouse, where the mouse is this Agent X, and the y is, is the cat. And, and they're each hoping to minimize their respective loss functions f and g, because the cat wants to get the mouse, and the mouse does not want to be gotten by the cat. So so. So the thing to notice here is that the loss of each of these two apps and the GS depends on what the other one does. And so it turns out that this is rather important. So what they had, or what the mouse does influences what the cat should do next, and vice versa. So and this can go back and forth. Actually, if you think about this, and sort of finite time steps, this can go back and forth sort of infinitely many times, like, what would I do if what would if he knew what I was going to do, and back and forth, and back and forth, and back and forth, until you reach an equilibrium? Okay, but we're gonna get to that a little bit more in a moment. But, but I'd like to get into just a little bit more detail here, because I think it's helpful. So one thing to notice here is that these two agents, they have conflicting goals. So what what is good for the mouse is bad for the cat and vice versa, which is shown here as the they are basically, in essence, opposite types of loss functions, which again, are akin to our sequence and since. And, and so one way of viewing this is, okay, well, why can't I just do my regular gradient descent type of algorithms or something like them, in order to solve this problem. So let's look at what regular gradient descent or what I like to call simultaneous gradient descent, looks like for for such a problem with two agents. So here, we have the update on x, and on the left, and the update on y on the right. And so what you see is that the what what the x will do only depends on what what the y did at the previous step. So the next the basically, the update only depends on y or the previous step. And vice versa, y only depends on what x did at the previous step. Okay, and so we can see that if one actually goes through with this strategy that is in these that's embodied in these two little equations, that this strategy actually diverge is even on quite simple examples. So if the loss function of F, H, and F is just this inner product between X and Y, which happens to be at odds with the loss function of g, so let's just define this. So there's like a triple equality here, as minus g because they want to do opposite things, they have opposite objectives, then this, this thing even diverges here. And so that's what's shown in the picture, where here basically, the state of the Agent X, and the agent y is plotted on this two dimensional axis. So that makes up one circle here. And then the arrow represents the direction that the basically the the loss functions are pointing you in. But we see that this this basically divergence in this spiral, like fashion, and the reason for that is because for example, if agent F were to play in a in for example, in this in Rock, Paper, Scissors, if the agent app were to play rock, then the agent why word art would know that next to pick paper. And then after agent observes that agent y, or Jeep pick paper, it would then pick scissor and back and forth and back and forth, and back and forth. And not only would you not converge, but you would actually diverge in this sort of spiral like fashion. So this type of typical gradient descent does not work on these types of game formulations that I've laid out in the previous slides. Oh, okay. So then the question is, how does one linearize a game such that we can get some type of gradient descent descent like algorithm because we know they are useful? In order to carry out this optimization in a way that doesn't have these nasty properties, and perhaps one that's even kind of good. So one idea is to just have one agent. So and where the optimal strategy is just the regularized, linear local approximation of what it should be doing. And the other is to have two agents where the optimal strategies are linearized local approximations for both of the agents. But then the question remains, how do you actually linearize in order to, to deal with these problems. And so I'm going to briefly go through the math of of how these terms show up. And hopefully that makes things a bit more interactive, and more and more interesting. And so here, let's look at what is basically essentially, straightforward gradient descent on the, the update to Agent X and the update to agent y on the top and bottom respectively. And so, here, well, what we see is that if this is linear for one agent, then it is actually linear for two agents. So this is just the gradient, what you're looking at at the top is just the gradient descent update for so how x should change. And here, this is just sort of the truncated Taylor series. So you have the argument of the objective function f. And then you have your your gradient terms and x and y that show up evaluated, of course, at x sub k y sub k, and then you have this regularization term that basically enforces or penalizes good or bad behavior, which looks like this inner product term. So this, this sort of corresponds to how big of a step you would take, given the competence that you have in your, in your objective function. And the same thing is on the bottom, except now we're looking at G's instead of apps. And we're looking at why is it set of axes, but otherwise, things are the same. And we still end up with these two terms showing up here except again, with with the G. Okay, and so I think the the interesting part that will that will come up here is that if you do this with sort of normal gradient descent, then and you and you linearize, this problem, what you will find is that all of these cross terms, the terms that pas perspective that that potentially could give the information about what the cat should do, knowing what the mouse would do, and what the mouse should do, knowing what the cat should do, are actually vanish, because this term does not depend on why. And then this term is evaluated such that is not evaluated at any, this derivative vanishes, because it's constant with respect to x, and vice versa here. So this term ends up being a constant, it goes away, this derivative with respect to x goes away. And so the only terms that you hold on to are the normalization terms, of course, and then these highlighted terms that are basically what we already went through, they're the terms that say, Okay, well, I'm the cat. So I know that I should be doing such and such. But it's not taking in this, this intrinsic, missing information about what the cat would do, knowing what the what the mouse would do. And vice versa. There's no sort of cross terms that exist here. So this actually just turns in the same goes for the mouse on the bottom. And so this just turns into simultaneous gradient descent, once again. But then, the interesting part is that there's there's no reason there's, there's actually additional terms that can be kept that are linear here. So the additional terms are these cross derivatives, in this case, T x y of the second derivative operator, that are shown in the middle here. And these represent what the cat would do knowing what the mouse would do, and vice versa. And they show up in both the both the top and the bottom terms. One thing to notice here is that even though this represents a Hashem, it only represents the off diagonal terms. So and so the there's, this is still linear, it is not nonlinear, and it doesn't result in any other nasty second order derivatives. Okay, and so this, this allows them basically both to peek at each other and go back and forth, back and forth in order to, to to make basically the best update. And now, and so this is an interactive type of procedure. Now, there's only one step left in this in this business, which is to find the Nash equilibrium, which is that if I know that you know that I know that you know about the steps that I'm going to make next then you can iterate this over and over and over again to find the Nash equilibrium where it no longer or makes sense for me to move in a certain direction, because knowing what you would do next, I would do nothing different, and vice versa. So, in this case, both players are satisfied with their positions, and then you make an update. And so it turns out that you can just get this from a truncated value decomposition and taking that to an infinite power, and then you get a Nash equilibrium. And so this thing serves as the new update rule that makes up the basis of CGD, or competitive gradient descent. So this is just the thing that that serves as our new update rule. And we argue that this is a natural generalization of gradient descent to multiple agents without bearing on undue computational costs or anything nasty like that. Okay, so that's how we actually go about our, our optimization procedure. And that, it turns out that the Nash equilibrium of this game, actually is the exact solution to the PDE. So So there's actually no conflict there that that's actually a nice mathematical fact that can be proven. Okay, so how does this thing perform, I report that this is such a such a nice idea or something that, I guess I should show some evidence that it has some some nice features. So here, what we do is the number of forward we count the number of forage passes instead of the number of epochs because in the sequence procedure, when asked to account for this Hutcheon vector, a product, this, which is associated with these cross terms that I mentioned that that makes CGD what it is, instead of just simultaneous gradient descent, so instead, in order to barely take, take into account the computational cost, we count the number of forward passes as opposed to the number of epochs. And then we plot that against LT relative error, which is nominally what you've actually care about. And we see that even on A to D Poisson problem, a nice, smooth one, nothing particularly nasty about it over about 123, like four orders of magnitude, the pin instance has the traditional pin trained with regular gradient descent here, with Adam, basically, with its special update rule has decreased by less than an order of magnitude over all of those forward passes in terms of LC relative error, whereas the C pen is able to get down to single precision error. So this is carried out on single precision hardware. So this is actually as good as we can hope to do. And it does it in an efficient way, as well. So so it works here nicely. And then the other argument that one, maybe thinking about making is is along the lines of, well, what about, you're saying you're using Atom will maybe I should just be using some orders, other special optimizer and that will take care of the problem. And we we actually did an ablation study on a whole slew of different algorithms, both the most popular ones and other ones that people more modern ones that people argue for. And we found that this red curve, which is the one that I presented before, called a CGD, which, where the A isn't particularly important, but the point is that it outperforms in a quite meaningful way. All of these other other things, other optimizers, which is great. And I also mentioned the difference between forward passes and epochs or iterations. So you see, if we actually just take into account iterations, then the then our method here, and red looks even better. But I think that's a bit of an unfair way of thinking about it. But I put it there just for reference. Okay, I have one more slide, I think. And it's on NewBay. Stokes. So there's been all sorts of efforts on trying to train the VA Stokes, and all sorts of papers just about training pins on the VA Stokes. And so we thought we would give it a go. And so, my argument here is that over all of these orders of magnitude of forward passes, basically the pen is not training at all. So this is being trained on a to solve a steady cavity flow problem, a lid driven cavity flow problem. And it decreases in relative error by like a factor of have like to over all of these forward iterations, the physics and form neural network without them. And to be clear again, I'm only showing the best results for the physics and form neural networks with for the various optimizers. I'm not showing the ones that do worse. And but for the C pen, we do get convergence. It's a bit noisy, which I have some ideas about why that may be but suffice it to say that it does seem to be converging, albeit quite slowly. So that This requires a bit more attention about what could be going on here. But it has some similar characteristics. Okay, so. So that's basically the end of my talk. And I hope I left enough time for questions. The key takeaways here is that there's a training problem that is associated with this, this squared loss function, and that remedying the squared loss function is not maybe as trivial as it seems. And it involves sort of actually changing the architecture of how one goes about solving this problem. And using sort of a little bit more specialized optimization methods, there are a bunch of good results that we have for other equations that I wouldn't burden you with showing you solutions for the burgers equation, Schrodinger LM con equation, so on and so forth. So we do quite well for those as well. And, and the new guy Stokes also does well but needs a bit more attention that we're looking into. So the code for this is openly available under MIT license, you're welcome to, to have it and play around with it if you if you see fit. So I'd like to thank you for your time and for the invitation. I hope this was in any way interesting. And of course, happy to take your questions. Thank you. Thank you so much for the wonderful talk, Spencer, very informative and easy to follow. My opinion. And also there were like tons of discussions in the follow every single things. But let's let's do this in q&a session. Let's give a you know, the chance to ask questions in you know, in verbally. Hopefully their sound works. Let's start with a Mark Miller. If you're okay to unmute yourself and ask your question directly, that'd be wonderful. Sure, maybe I'll just ask the last one great talk. I wasn't able to follow all of it. But I really enjoyed it. So I had a silly question here towards the end. What do you have a sense of maybe what the total flop count is for solutions via sea pin versus traditional numerical solutions? The same quality? Yeah, good question. So we try to take that into account with our business of forward passes versus iterations here. So actually, what's going into this forward pass computation is we actually we aren't taking into account per se, the exact lob count, because that could could become a bit more complicated one thinks about that people are doing you would normally do this on GPUs. So I'm not sure that that flop count, per se, is the perfect metric. But um, but instead, what we do is we just take into account the nominal number of sort of operations that are required in order to do the Hessian vector product, which is the main thing that actually changes the cost between the regular pin and the C pen. So that's the main difference. And that is the thing that we add to the cost, which gives this difference between the plot on the left and the plot on the right, in terms of shifting this red curve to the right, as well as the yellow curve, that's somewhat less less important. Okay, Mark, Mark is talking about the traditional numerical methods like the finite element, finite difference, by the way? Oh, are you talking it? Oh, sorry. If you're Yeah. I'm totally totally misunderstood. It's one, it's one I totally get all the time. So I can. So yeah, yeah. So your question to that is, if I understand correctly, is, well, what if I want to just solve the same problem using a finite element method to solve the PDE? The same way. So I, I totally sympathize with everyone that wants to do this. And I actually suggest you do it. If you have a traditional solver to solve via finite elements or something, your 2d Poisson equation and you're happy with that, there will actually be much faster to deal with that than to deal with training a pin and solving it that way. Not only will you get smaller errors in your traditional solver, but you will solve it faster. Now, the ends what I what I sort of hit here and maybe I should have shouldn't have is that the real value in these pins things in my view, and maybe other people have other views, but the main value is that these things are useful for many query problems, many query meaning that I can train this pin to also be be parametric. So you know, you can imagine the flow over an airfoil. And then I train this pin on a whole bunch a whole bunch of PDs where the where the parameter is, say the angle of attack. And now I can probe that thing as basically for free because the thing is represented as this small, compact, nice little neural network. But if you want to solve a million finite elements, solve the finite element equations a million times for different angles of attack, then then I would argue that that's, that's not really a very fruitful way to go. And the more promising area here is these many query problems. Super, thanks. Thanks so much. Really enjoyed it. Thank you. Thank you. Let's go to magic magic. View. Hello, can you hear me? Yep. Yeah. So I didn't actually write any questions in the chat. But I can ask you a question if that's okay. Yes, thanks for a great talk, actually, I mean, I did a study feels a little bit different from many other applications. So it's nice to get to the root of the problem with pins. My question is, so the problems that you showed here, like day to day problems? I'm just wondering, do you think finding the best optimizer will solve all the problems with pins or using neural networks to solve PDS? For instance, for let's say, problems that they have time component, or 3d or where you have high frequencies and things like that? Yeah, I guess my question is, like, what? So I see, they can be one problem with optimization, right. And they can be one problem with neural net for not being expressive enough to solve every kind of PDE video with. So just wanted wondering about your comments, you know, like your thoughts on that? Okay. Yes, thank you for your question. I think I understand it. So the so there's a couple of things first, number one, I should say, I don't purport. And I hope I didn't give the impression that I that we're somehow solving every pin problem that exists, just maybe a couple of the ones that people have been noticing often. And that seems to be important to get into the bottom of some of these other things. So that's, that's the deal with this, this conditioning that can be solved via a mini max type of architecture and the competitive optimizer. So that can be what solved there. Now, regarding your sort of other questions, whether one is whether whether one is thinking about higher dimensional problems. So the part of the reason I actually didn't solve show fighter higher dimensional problems is that higher dimensional problems are actually easier for a pin like thing, or really any type of neural network type architecture, because they don't suffer from the curse of dimensionality in the same way that a traditional solver would. So if you had, for example, and a lot of people do this, and perhaps it's a bit unfair to for them to do so. But point is that as you go to higher and higher dimensions, so if I think of like the 10 D Poisson problem, all of a sudden a neural network type solution for that problem actually looks very, very competitive compared to any type of traditional solution to that problem. Because as the, the the expressivity of the neural network remains intact, but the expressivity or the amount of operations that one would have to do to solve this in a in a sort of normal numerical methods way does not, and it scales to the power of that dimension. So that's a nasty problem. And And actually, that's another place maybe if I were to add another bullet point, down here to this slide, it would be also useful for many dimensional problems. And so if those are interests of up to you, then things like these types of neural network expressivity, things are quite attractive. The other point you made was just regarding expressivity in terms of what if my, my solution to my PDE has, let's say, some really nasty features some highly escalatory features or something like that? Does the neural network have enough expressivity in order to accommodate for those kinds of solutions? At least if that, if I'm understanding the? And I think so there's a couple of things. One is that this, there's this idea of the neural networks serve as universal approximator. So and So which I think in many cases is used as a bit of a red herring. But the point is that, but but the point is still true, is that for a sufficiently deep and wide neural network, any type of solution can be expressed. So so that's, that is true. And now, now what in more practical terms, if one had a really nasty equation, and what would How big would the neural network have to be? And would it be worth making a neural network that large in order to get that kind of expressivity is a question that I'm not really prepared to answer, but it would, but in some limit, it would be able to do so. Interesting. Thank you. Thank you for your comments. Great talk. Thank you. Okay, thank you. Let's move on to repairing. I know, he just commented on it. But let's give him a chance. Oh, wait. Thanks. Thank you. Thank you. If I can ask some questions. This is a very good talk. I'm very interested in this topic. I think my first question is up, actually, and that's on the slide you you're showing here, I think, at the very beginning of your talk, you'll set some good features up of pin, because you don't need the much data and you have some information in the back propagation. I think I didn't hear that very well. Can you? Can you please comment down that again? Absolutely. Yeah. So this comes down to the crux of what a pin actually is, which is the idea that I, what I want to do is I want to solve a PDE. So what I'm showing here is a toy PDE a Poisson problem. So I have the Laplacian of u equals F. And so I'm just basically sticking this thing into the loss function or the error, the mismatch, the result, the mismatch in the residual, basically, is going into the loss function. And these are just the first time here is just associated with boundary conditions. So maybe we can maybe we can forget that for the moment. So that's the idea of a pen. And then the reason that this all sort of works out nicely is because one can, one doesn't need any data, because one can obtain these derivatives. So in this case, I need the second derivatives with respect with respect to the independent variable operating on you in order to compute the Laplacian, right? But the thing is, through backpropagation, I can get, I can just basically do auto grad to get all of those derivatives for free. So this comes to the case where, where I don't actually need some sort of data or anything, I can automatically compute what those derivatives should be. And I can just take them into the loss function. So basically, back propagating through the neural network to compute what the what the derivatives are. So at times, you can approximate or you can put up any sort of PDE into this thing. Gotcha. Thank you. My second question is, I think you showed one of the problem in not achieving high accuracy in pin is the loss function. So you have you because we monitor this read you do? Yeah, especially in this linear algebra sense, a U equals to F. I think a lot of traditional methods like Jim RAS is also a minimization problem based on residual the based on the residual norm. Doesn't seem is too much a problem for Krylov method or other traditional numerical method. But it seems like the conditioning is a really a pain. In this context. Do you have comments on that? Yes, right. So good point. Yeah. So yeah, so one can argue about whether or not whether or not this problem of this this sort of squared condition number is pervasive to all minimize errors, or whether one can just somehow pick a better minimizer and be okay. Part of the thing here is that this is, and that's part of the limitations of this linear algebra example is that is it just just a linear algebra example. And if one wanted to do this on the actual sort of through the neural network, then then something like Krylov subspace method would not be appropriate. And MGM res would suffer in the same way. So basically, the only way, as far as I'm aware, to get round this is to give away the P equals two norm to give or to give away any P, P even norm. And, and to settle with like a P one norm, but that has its own problems to settle for an odd for an odd norm. That that would be a solution. But I think but it comes with other problems that I think would not be conducive to, to the type of things that people usually care about. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Okay, thank you. Let's move on to John Ragosa. That's giving you a chance to ask question, John, a thank you. Great talk. I liked it a lot, very interested in paint. I would have lots of issues with paint. So maybe I'll send you an email later. But let me just ask you a couple of questions. If there's time. Have you tried cases where the PD has greatly varying coefficients? Let's say for example, as in, you know, heat conduction problem that you have conductivity is in different materials and the conductivity is maybe vary by factor, let's say 1000. So, really severely heterogeneous cases can see the pins approach seems to always find solutions that are overly two diffusive. And they'll have sharp gradients. And I'd be interested to know what you think of those more real life situations with with heterogeneous problems. Ah, yeah, we have a problem that can't, that you can't normalize the scale. So yeah, I guess you have these nasty sort of rough coefficients that you're talking about, then? The quick answer is no, I haven't tried it. And maybe I should, um, and whether or not I suspect that something like what I presented is somehow a cure to that or not. I don't I don't know. I mean, the, like your your comments about the the fact that your your pin result gives on this type of highly heterogeneous problem gives a say, overly diffusive solution or something like this. It's not, I guess, one would first have to know what what to really attribute that problem to, which can be a challenge. But I mean, it's not clear to me immediately, whether that's due to maybe whether or not the pin has been sufficiently trained. Or, and so the loss function is sufficiently low, because another thing that is, is, at least intellectually interesting about pins is that they can come up with solutions to PDE s, because there's no data involved, right? So they can come up with solutions to PDS that are also that are that are solutions. But they just aren't the one that you were thinking you would get. So so so people have actually used this to find to like show that maybe you can actually get like non unique solutions to things like the navier stokes equations. So actually, a recent, some recent papers on on the Millennium prize type problems for TVA Stokes, have touched upon that. So that's another possibility. But unfortunately, I can't really speak much more to, to the to the type of problem you're talking about. No worries, I think I'd send you an email later today. Maybe this weekend, I'll tell you a few things. But what I'm, what I'm doing and what the issues I'm having. Now, I have another quick question. If you think Sue allows me to skyrocket quick. Okay, very, very quick. What do you think? What do you think of training the new generation of graduate students on those tools? Should they also learn traditional methods? Or is it always is going to be a thing of the past? I'm just curious what your opinion is on this trend training them to do what to do these kinds of neural network type things? Yeah, yeah. You know, maybe maybe there will be a less emphasis on learning, you know, finite elements, find a different type of themes of, you know, what we call traditional methods. What do you think with this takeover? Is there room for techniques? Who? Well, there's some some tension in between the two? What's your opinion? I think people are trying these things, because they partially because they're trendy, and partially because they've run out of other options. But of course, yes, young young folks coming into grad school, want to try the trendy things? That's, that has always been the case. And and, and pins is definitely not the first example of that. And sometimes these things prove to stand sort of the test of time, so to speak, and, and sometimes they do not. So I guess I don't claim to have any, any more clairvoyance on the app. But I do think that I mean, only boy thing I think is that anything that involves not thinking about the math, behind these things, in some sort of careful way, is very risky, because you end up in this situation where your results may not be good, and you have no way to reason about why they aren't good. And so if you don't understand the math, then you're you're really out of luck, because the neural network also is opaque so it doesn't offer you. It doesn't offer you some sort of something of some other information in which you can sort of inform your priors and make a better choice about a model or a differential equation or something like that. Yeah, thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you. Let's move on to Henry. Henry. Are you there? Oh, hi. Hi, I'm here. Can you hear me? Yeah. And you can ask questions. Oh, sure. Hi. Yeah, thank you. Thank you for your talk, I just wonder if so you use the PD residual as your loss function that you want to minimize in your problem. So I was just wondering, what are your thoughts on like, does it make sense to use like a physics space functional? By for example, like for the diffusion equation, you can define the thermal dissipation functional? And then you can just minimize that to get your solution for diffusion equation like, what are your thoughts on using that as your last function? Right? So a pin in this context, at least only purports to be able to only purports to be solving a PDE, that is prescribed and now, while you're, I think alluding to is the idea of adding additional terms that are associated with the physics that may also be relevant. And so one can, of course, pile on these sorts of additional constraints and terms in the in soft terms into the loss function in the hopes of getting a better result. But then it's just a matter of what do you consider a better result? If what people have been playing around with this idea, if I go back to here, what that basically, there's whole, there's whole spaces here, where people are thinking about physics guided loss functions, right, all the way down here. So all of these papers are thinking about, how do I add things to that are relevant to the physics that are maybe aside from just the PDE? And if there's one thing that I've learned, it's that these things are a bit hard to say? They I think they kind of missed the point that if the neural network is, is behaving appropriately, and in a way that you expect, then you don't need these things. And so and so in a sense, they're kind of stopgap sort of solutions to get something that looks kind of how you want it to look. But if, but otherwise, if it's if it's not giving you the solution that you expect that the know, maybe there's something more interesting going on, which is what we found. And I think, I think that that's actually why the things that are shown in the slides here, have gone sort of unnoticed for so long, because people were thinking about these other types of things, and not just thinking about, like, what is like the actual math going on in this thing. Okay. Oh, thanks. Thank you. Okay, let's move to while it are you, there is thank you for the opportunity. And thank you for the great presentation. I'm really glad that someone is finally addressing the loss functions and the optimization issues associated with Ben's my question, my first question is in regards to the boundary conditions you're using for the poisons equation, if you can describe him briefly. I believe that we just did. Periodic? No, I think, no, no, sorry, just dear slave boundary conditions are correctly on that problem. It will be interesting to see if you can use some Neumann boundary conditions with sources and sinks. Because that could be a very challenging problem. My second question is in regards to mixing other types of loss losses in the loss function. So if you had some data, so you have a different type of, let's say, a mean squared error with the min max loss function, is that something that's possible? Yes, it's certainly possible, either a priori, a posteriori. I mean, that's the other part of what was actually inside of the, the, the paper here. So yes, you certainly can add these other data, data constraints. So if you know that, that the data is whatever it is that you can add, you can add it to perhaps to better do better here in terms of your training and get a better result. The only concern that I sometimes have about mixing and matching these two things is that the data comes with its own uncertainties and whether or not the data is behaving exactly as the PDE that you stick in this loss function is may not be always clear. So whether or not it's obeying the exact you know, incompressible, navier stokes or something to this effect, is is not always obvious. And if that is the case, then you could end up with this sort of tension between these two different types of loss function that may not give the results you expect. And but that that's, that's It's like a pin thing, not necessarily something specific to the type of architecture that I was talking about. Or Thank you very much. Thanks. Great talk. Thank you. Okay, John, we're gonna Are you there? Oh, maybe he's not there. But he loved the chat in the chat. Great. Oh, can you please share the paper and the code in the chat? Yeah. So well, I don't have access to the chat at the moment. But they're, they're here. And then they'll be they'll be available there. They're also just on my website. So yeah. All right. Sounds good. feed you. Are you there? Just a very generic question. So Kennedy's idea of min max method is to a min max problem be applied to generic regression problems? Can it be applied to what? Sorry, say it again? Regression over general regression problems? Um, yes. Yes, it can. It's just that I'm not sure the benefits are so obvious. It depends on what kind of regression problem you have. But if Ebina for if the regression problem is solving is has the same types of poor conditioning, then we can certainly reformulate this sort of loss function this way. And so that, yeah, so there's, there's many applications of this type of competitive tension that give that that are useful. And one can find them in the in the papers that are referenced in our paper, of which there are many. And you can, and you can have a look and see there, there really are quite a few. I just didn't have time to talk about all of them. All right. Thank you. Stop here. Are you there? He's not there. All right. So that's the all I have on the chat. But is there anyone who wants to ask questions on mute yourself? So that's a quick question. Yeah, boy, yeah. Yeah. This is Andrew Jillette. I really enjoyed your talk. Thank you. I'm curious. There's some work that was like gradient informed pin where they do slightly better than pin results by incorporating gradient information. Have you compared your work to that? And if so, how did it compare? No, we compared our work to many different what I would call training tricks. Where one ads basically one's trying to accelerate training or somehow ameliorate these costs that are that show up in order to get better results. And so there's a whole sort of alphabet soup of different pin methods. And, and so it's true that I think these gradient things do give better results. There's, there's, I guess two things I would note, the first is that none of them seem to my eyes to actually address what is the actual problem. And so I mean, if you can get a better solution without addressing the actual problem, then I think I mean, that's fine. But I, at the very least, I wanted to, to note it, to note that this is what what what is likely going on. And, and the other is that these many of these other sort of training tricks that, that that one of which you're alluding to, but but there are others, like, like, like mini batching, and all these other things. We've tried some of them because reviewers wanted to see them. But in principle, they can all be just added to our method anyway. So in some sense, they're in different categories. Make sense? Thank you. Thank you. Sounds good. Well, it's seven ft. 11. Spencer, thank you so much for staying with us for the extra time. I was able to get to some of these questions. Wonderful. Okay, so I'm sure there are more questions, but let's wrap up here. And then Oh, yeah. Say hi to someone is good to meet you here. Hope you're having a good time at Lawrence Livermore on your in your first week? Yeah, it is first week. Yeah. I am having a Good Time hear it. Yeah. Very good. Awesome. Well, thank you, Spencer again. Let's think. Applause one more time. And yeah, I mean, I hope you will increase the collaboration with the Lawrence Livermore National Lab as well. I mean, as you do with other other other national lab, right, or preacher and the Sandia National Lab, right, please consider us okay. So It'd be my pleasure. All right. Sounds good. Okay, let me push the stop button for the recording.